[Musique]
car elle Ménard dirige un groupe
environnemental spécialisé en gestion
des déchets au Québec de temps à autre
il fait le tour des centres de tri on
documente un petit peu ce qui se passe
dans les principaux centres de tri on
est passé à travers plusieurs crises du
recyclage et pour nous ça donne des
indications de ce qui se passe
en janvier nous l'avons accompagné
devant un centre dans la région de
Montréal ça c'est des ballots de fibres
donc du papier du carton mélangé on voit
aussi le visuellement beaucoup de
plastique tout ce qui est bleu
sur de loin les matières principales
traitées par les centres de tri le
papier mixte et la catégorie de moindre
qualité parce qu'il est souvent
contaminé par d'autres rebuts
principalement du plastique et il est
encore majoritairement exporté donc le
client qui va acheter ça va devoir faire
un surprise c'est à dire retrier et
c'est pour ça souvent qu'on exporte ça à
l'étranger là parce que les la main
d'oeuvre dans les pays notamment en Asie
et beaucoup moins cher et les normes
environnementales n'ont plus sont pas
très présentes
en fait des quantités colossales de
plastique de mauvaise qualité sont
envoyés illégalement à l'étranger sous
le radar dans des ballots de papier
l'an dernier c'est un inspecteur
environnemental belge qui nous avait mis
la puce à l'oreille il avait intercepté
au port d'Anvers 20 conteneurs de papier
mixte fortement contaminés provenant
d'un centre de tri de Montréal opéré par
la compagnie ricova
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de plastique
c'est impossible de recycler ces 500
triage très profond
au cours des années précédentes
l'inspecteur avait saisi plusieurs
autres cargaisons de déchets souillés
venant de différentes provinces
canadiennes toutes à destination de
l'Inde
problème avec les contenus de papier qui
venant du Canada
selon lui le taux de contamination des
ballots examinés devant nous étaient au
moins
25%. une proportion qui enfreint
largement la réglementation
internationale
[Musique]
nous nous étions rendus en Inde dans
l'une des régions qui achètent le papier
à recycler étranger nous avions été
renversés par la grande quantité de
déchets plastiques Canadiens dans ces
décharges à ciel ouvert et nous avions
découvert qu'une grande partie du
plastique était couramment brûlée
clandestinement
[Musique]
à la suite du reportage le gouvernement
fédéral a bloqué plusieurs cargaisons de
l'entreprise ricova et elle lui a imposé
de strictes conditions d'opérations pour
la forcer à respecter la loi sur
l'environnement
recova a réagi en réduisant à 2%, le
taux de contamination des ballots de
papier mixte sortant de son centre de
tri de Saint Michel selon ses données
internes du mois de janvier
au port d'Anvers marque de Strooper a
d’abord observé en 2022 une amélioration
de la qualité des ballots de papier
mixte venant du Canada mais dans les
derniers mois le nombre d'interceptions
est à nouveau en hausse j'ai pensé que
l'exportation était améliorée mais
depuis le début de cette année-ci j'ai
déjà trouvé
11 conteneur avec du papier contaminé
mais tout ce papier vient surtout du
côté de Toronto
[Musique]
nous avons demandé à nos collaborateurs
Indiens de retourner dans la région de
muzafarnagar pour voir si la situation
avait évolué
[Musique]
cette entrepreneur est content les
déchets étrangers ont continué d'affluer
ici
il est l'un des sous-traitants informels
à qui les papetières envoient les rebuts
extraits des ballots de papier importés
pour environ 3 dollars par jour ces
femmes font un tri supplémentaire pour
extraire les restes de plastique dur et
de métal qui ont une valeur commerciale
et du plastique mou retiré des ballots
brûle toujours dans des conditions
dangereuses
notre collègue journaliste Manoche pâle
a facilement trouvé des restes de
plastique carbonisés
[Musique]
de petites usines de fabrication de
sucre s'en servent encore comme
combustible mêlé aux résidus de canne à
sucre
des papetières ont brûlent aussi à plus
grande échelle souvent en cachette la
nuit elle rejette des cendres partout et
libèrent des substances chimiques
toxiques comme les dioxines et les
furanes
[Musique]
hier soir c'est un grave danger pour la
santé c'est très sérieux
les propriétaires des 33 usines de pâte
et papier ne prennent pas leur
responsabilité sociale nous sommes à
l'époque les autorités et l'industrie
papetière nier le problème mais ce
sous-préfet du district arrivé en poste
cet automne reconnaît qu'il faut agir
nous nous sommes assis avec l'industrie
des portes des papiers j'ai rencontré
les dirigeants de chaque compagnie et je
les ai avertis c'est notre
responsabilité collective de protéger
notre environnement
son équipe a mené récemment des raids
dans 4 papiers et pris des mesures à
l'encontre de 34 sucreries
notre pays est utilisé comme un dépotoir
par les pays développés
[Musique]
pas suffisantes il est membre d'un
groupe de jeunes militants locaux qui
tentent de stopper cette pollution
[Musique]
quand les médias on parle ou que
l'administration locale intervient
ça s'arrête pendant un moment
puis ça recommence
rien ne me permet de dire que la
situation est sous contrôle
plusieurs dites à déménager
de nombreuses personnes dans le village
travaillent dans ses usines
si elle protestent elles perdront leur
emploi nous sommes découragés
du papier à recycler de l'étranger car
elle n'en produit pas suffisamment
le hic c'est tout ce plastique mou
qu'elle reçoit en même temps ce
plastique officiellement recyclable
selon ses fabricants mais dans les faits
difficilement récupérables
depuis 2021 les règlements
internationaux se sont resserrés pour
l'exportation des déchets plastiques de
mauvaise qualité vers les pays en
développement mais le papier reste une
façon de contourner les nouvelles règles
[Musique]
dirige l'organisme Basel Action Network
qui milite contre le commerce
international des déchets dangereux
que ce plastique qui circule sous un
autre libellule comme le papier ou
l'idée chez électronique
dans les ballots de papier que ce qu'ils
importent officiellement comme plastique
il faut fermer cette échappatoire nous
essayons d'alerter le monde à ce sujet
des exportateurs trouvent toujours de
nouvelles façons d'échapper aux
inspections
de dire que c'est du carton donc c'est
caché derrière le gâteau ils peuvent
mettre même mettre un premier ligne de
carton dans le conteneur derrière la
porte et après ça le papier il y a
tellement de milliers de millions de
conteneurs qui circulent comment est-ce
qu'on peut vraiment contrôler tout ça il
faut vraiment
faire le travail à la source chez vous
c'est là qu'il faut faire
de plus de travail
[Musique]
le travail à la source c'est encore plus
de contrôle dans les ports de départ
canadien c'est aussi d'améliorer la
qualité des ballots sortant des centres
de tri
au Québec comme dans le reste de
l'Amérique du Nord le défi est encore
plus grand parce qu'on mélange toutes
les matières dans un même bac
la société via est un organisme sans but
lucratif qui emploie des gens ayant des
limitations fonctionnelles elle gère 5
centres de tri dans la province dont
celui-ci de Québec et elle est souvent
cité en exemple
énormément d'équipements ces
équipements-là vont nous apporter une
qualité qui peut aller jusqu'à
95%, mais pour se rendre jusqu'à 97 98
99% de qualité mais là ça prend des
contrôleurs qualité donc ça prend des
humains qui sont là qui vont faire un
travail quand même qui est très
difficile on est debout dans la
poussière pour avoir des odeurs mais ça
prend beaucoup de triangles
Jean-Sébastien d'aigle affirme que la
moyenne de contamination dans ses
ballots de papier mixte aussi entre deux
et 5%. la plupart des centres de tri
avec l'aide du gouvernement ont investi
argent et efforts pour améliorer la
qualité de leur matière mais malgré ses
améliorations beaucoup de plastique est
encore envoyé à l'étranger
d'autant plus que selon les statistiques
commerciales les exportations
canadiennes de papier mixtes Verlaine
ont augmenté en 2022
qui sont pas nécessaires mais avec
lesquels on a on a appris à vivre et on
est devenu dépendant au plastique puis
il faut s'en débarrasser d'une façon
d'une autre et les compagnies sont pas
responsables maintenant elles ne sont
pas responsables elles vont le devenir à
terme ce qui est une excellente chose
d'ailleurs
le véritable coup de barre au Québec
pour réduire notre production plastique
on l'espère en 2025 quand justement les
fabricants de contenants d'emballage et
d'imprimés deviendront responsables du
recyclage de leurs produits
[Musique]
donc de donner la responsabilité aux
producteurs donc à ceux qui produisent
cette excellent parce qu'il peut être
qui vont s'assurer de mettre un marché
des produits qui pourront recycler parce
que ça va être eux la propriété de la
matière va leur appartenir
[Musique]
on promet aussi plus de traçabilité des
cibles de qualité et de miser sur le
recyclage local
[Musique]